Now, let's look at
the Image Acquisition Pipeline.
This is something again, we've discussed
differently, when we talked about
cameras, but now, let's talk about it,
in detail in this context.
Of course, we start off with a 3D scene.
And of course this scene is being
captured, and the, basically,
the capturing in, information is called
the Scene Radiance refered to as L.
And basically,
what the units here describe is
watts per steradian meters squared.
Steradian is a measure of the solid
angle, and because these are 3D scenes,
and the light is coming out, in form
of a cone from everywhere the basic
idea we want to do is use the cone
information, to capture the light.
So in essence what that basically
means is if I have a scene,
what I will be doing
basically is using a cone.
And the steradian is basically,
kind of, counting for
all of the [INAUDIBLE] information
that's in this cone, from any point.
And that's basically,
allows us to kind of have an area,
from that point onwards.
To just reiterate scene radiance,
and referred to as L, is basically,
watts, which is energy per
steradian meters square.
Steradian is the measure
of the solid angle.
Primarily because again,
this is a 3D scene, and
the light is coming out in form
of a cone, from everywhere.
Of course, when we have a 3D scene,
to capture an image from it,
what do we need?
Of course, Optics.
So here, basically now,
we use the out Lens, and Optics, and
that converts all of this
3D light information.
That's why, we have the solid angle,
and the cone basically, coming in.
And now, of course, we have a 2D sensor.
So we, of course, do not have
the information from steradians, but
we do have watt per meter square.
And we know, that was something we
referred to as Sensor Irradiance, and
it's something we ip, in, labeling as E.
This is a Linear mapping.
Once I know this, and if have this
information, when it hits the screen,
I can actually now, or a sensor,
I know, what this measure will be.
Next stage in the pipeline of course,
is the Shutter,
because shutter is the amount of time,
a light is allowed into my sensor.
And we know that basically,
E times delta t gives us the information
towards getting, the sensor exposure.
And you may recall of course, that we
refer to the exposure as H, which was
equal to the sensor irradiance, and
amount of time, the shutter was open.
And this is something again,
we've looked at before,
so in essence we'll be going
from 3D scene, and now,
we're getting sensor information
of the exposure values.
Continuing on, we basically now, will
have a sensor, which would be a CCD,
again, we've covered
the details of how a CCD works.
Light comes into a CCD, and what we
basically, get is electrons collecting,
and depletion layer kind of,
collects it.
In essence, what we're doing
is computing the voltages,
at different types of capacitors,
within a CCD.
Next step of course, is an analog to
digital converter, basically, takes
these voltages, and converts them into a
digital values, to give you a raw image.
And of course, then we want to do some
sort of remapping, from the raw image,
again, if you were doing camera roll,
you would just use this information.
But sometimes you basically,
get compressed pixel information
of intensities, and that's where
we get the intensities artifact.
We have covered each, and
every aspect of this earlier, and
you can refer back to the previous
lectures on this one.
But the bottom line is, from 3D scene,
once we have the scene radiance,
there's a linear mapping,
to get sensor irradiance.
There's another linear
mapping based on again,
the time opening to get the exposures.
And then, there is a bunch of
different operations that happen,
at the sensor level.
So, here is one thing we
want to note here is,
this whole process of
the pipeline is linear.
There are lots of linear
mappings going on.
This part could all be non-linear,
right?
I mean, there are no dir, direct
linear equations that would actually,
let us predict this analysis here.
And they're also sometimes depends
on the kinds of sensors, and stuff.
But this is linear, and now, we need
to kind of understand, how we can
use this to understand, and gain
information, from what's in the scene,
to what we want on the sensor,
in terms of an exposure.
So far, we've studied the image
acquisition pipeline, now,
let's look at some of
the mathematics associated with it.
So, of course, this whole pipeline
starts off with L which is the scene
radiance, a linear mapping to E,
a linear mapping to exposure, and
then, of course, all the way down here,
to give me intensity values.
Of course, we're interested in this
pipeline, but we are also interested in
the inverse of this pipeline,
which let's me compute the inverse.
Now, we are basically, what I am
interested in, is I have an image,
can I actually now, predict the model
of the whole scene intensities here,
in terms of scene radiance?
So, I'm interested in both of those.
And that's the kind of stuff now let's
think about, to be able to model.